Eric were aware that you've written over
40 books some of which are on creativity
and some I believe are on other topics
of those 40-plus books is there one or
two that stands out the most in terms of
the feedback that you receive from
artists on how helpful those books have
been for them and if so what is that
feedback yeah actually there are a
couple that seem to stand out one is the
van Gogh blues which is about
existential sadness and the creative
life a lot of people seem to resonate
with the idea that if they're not doing
meaningful work they're not actually
feeling emotionally well and a lot of
the so called depression out there which
is a pseudo medical sounding diagnosis
depression is really sadness and despair
around not having the opportunity to do
meaningful work or if given the
opportunity how that opportunity often
turns into less than meaningful work but
certainly a a Hollywood challenge where
maybe you get the gig but then so many
hands stir that pot that the ultimate
film doesn't feel as meaningful as it
might have so the van Gogh blues there's
one book that people seem to like that
artists seem to like and another is a
book called coaching the artist within
where I go over eight or ten or twelve I
can't quite remember important lessons
and tell some vignette - story is about
clients I've worked with so I would say
those are the two books that maybe I get
the most feedback on interesting do you
think most artists are essentially
afraid of failure or afraid of success
if I had to get percentages I would say
92% they're afraid of failure and 8%
they're afraid of success and those are
joke numbers of course I saw mostly
people are afraid of failing
sometimes they're afraid of the kinds of
work that goes with successful like
interviews or paparazzi or or or not
being able
to be a sort of secluded secretive
person any longer so there are some
challenges with success that folks do
sometimes worry about but I do think
that it's the terror fear of failure
that's most prevalent Eric turning to
your own work I'm curious how how
successful was was your first book
called a first-look weird where do we go
back to there you know we're talking
probably 45 years ago now which is a
while and my first books no one wanted
and because I was a an arrogant
narcissistic grandiose young man when
somebody would tell me what I would need
to do in order to get a book published I
would tell them to go someplace so it
took a long time for me to have any
success I had a ghost writing career
which was very interesting where you
could give me the title of a book and I
would write you a book on that subject
didn't matter what didn't matter what
the title was didn't matter what the
book was and so for many years I was
churning out books on all kinds of
oddball subjects some of which were
quite successful although I didn't make
any money from them because they were
for hire gig so I would get a certain
amount upfront and then that's all I
would see on it I would say probably I
was in I was it wasn't until I was in my
mid 40s that the nonfiction started to
be successful and my first non-fiction
book was called staying sane in the arts
and that did fairly well and then the
book that followed it a book called
fearless creating did quite well so
that's that's a long answer to a short
question and the long answer is I think
probably with heroes creating that was
my first real success interesting so I
think at some point within that time
though you became a therapist and and
did you then go back and look at some of
your own ups and downs in life from that
therapeutic model and
come up with sort of this creativity
coaching how did that work yeah not so
much that way
I started out as a novelist at some
point in my early 30s because I wasn't
making enough money as a novelist I
retooled and became a California
licensed family therapist as I was in
training for that I had the opportunity
at a Counseling Center to run a series
called something like growth and healing
through the arts or something I can't
remember what it was called but he gave
me the opportunity to bring in folks
from the community from the San
Francisco Bay Area community who I
thought maybe you were working with
artists on their issues if that turned
out not to be the case I didn't
understand the lingo back then as a
beginning therapist so I did bring in
art therapists and other folks and what
I discovered was that nobody was really
working on artist issues or working
specifically with skatin performing
artists this was before the artists way
this was a long time ago and so I
realized that I had a niche there if I
wanted it I could focus on working with
create and performing artists as a
therapist and that's what I did I
started I probably started doing the
hardest work in the world which was
working with artist couples in therapy
there may be nothing harder than that
I'm right funny but that's when I began
understanding artist issues deeply was
in working with creative folks it wasn't
so much sort of reflecting on my own
journey but rather sitting across from
folks with challenges and beginning to
deeply understand those challenges the
more I worked with clients over the
years I've been doing this now for a
very long time can it remember 30 plus
years so that's a lot of experience
working with a lot of folks and and for
yourself how much of your own advice do
you apply to yourself when when maybe
you're working through something that
you'd rather put off and you employ some
of your own techniques that's close to a
hundred percent as I can pull off I
believe in the advice I give great I
believe that if we don't do our work in
a regular way
don't maintain a creativity practice
whatever that means for us that weeks
and months can slip by unnoticed one of
the biggest challenges for creative
person is that when they skip two or
three days of their work suddenly a
years gone by they nor know where it
went so I try to maintain my regularity
and routine I consider those sort of
sacred words regularity and routine and
scheduling and planning and all of those
things I completely believe in the word
process it's probably the most important
word in my vocabulary I know that I
can't know things before I know them if
I'm starting out on a book I can't
really know what the books about
until I try to write the book and find
out what it's about
so I believe in the reality and I would
say even the elegance of process with a
truthful process so to make this answer
a little shorter I try to follow my own
advice what is your process when it
comes to your writing well it's pretty
straightforward in the sense that the
number one thing is showing up and I try
to show up every day to my work and by
everyday I mean every day because I
don't think that we don't have meaning
needs on the weekends I think we need to
maintain meaning and our emotional
well-being by working all the time so I
try to get to my work seven days a week
that's the main part of process and the
other main part of process is to not
attach throughout comes I'm really not
worried about how the world will react
to things I'm not really worried about
whether something will be wanted I'm not
in control of that all I can do is a my
work and then be the marketing of my
work I do believe it's in my power to
influence the reception of my work by
being a smart marketer by having and
making connections by being pleasant
rather than arrogant etc so I believe in
those two things as parts of process
namely showing up to the work and then
showing up to the marketing of the work
so I want to go back to your I think
it's 2007 book the van Gogh blues and
just talk a little bit more about the
existential depression that you see a
lot of creative people experience and I
think I heard you say before that that a
lot of its from wanting to put out
something very like culturally relevant
very life-changing for a lot of people
out in the world and and sometimes that
works and sometimes it doesn't is that
right yeah it's a complicated business
so let me try to tease out some
headlines okay first of all it's
important to understand what the meaning
is and for me my understanding of what
meaning is is that it's a certain kind
of psychological experience it's not
something objective out there
the universe has no particular purpose
for us or the universe universe has no
particular meaning it's more that
meaning is a certain kind of
psychological experience which we can
influence and try to provoke into being
and I have a lot of language around this
about ceasing meaning opportunities of
making meaning investments that's all by
way of saying that there isn't one thing
and one thing only
that provokes the psychological
experience of meaning and us creative
people tend to not know that or forget
that and they often feel like it's only
their creative work that can give them
the experience of meaning they don't
actually have a robust enough menu of
meaning opportunities and so if they're
acting life isn't working or their film
making life isn't working they're down
they're depressed they're sad maybe even
despairing because they don't have
enough of the experience of meaning in
their life because they haven't realized
that they have to make other kinds of
meaning investments in life also like in
relationships or in service or we could
name a whole array of things that also
amount to meaning opportunities so one
of the let's call it errors mental
mistakes that a creative person can make
is to put all of his or her meaning eggs
into the creativity basket we have too
many too too many cases too many
instances the creative folks who have
been creative wildly creative and still
commit suicide because
being creative hasn't produced enough
meaning in their life and Bango pops to
mind but we could name all kinds of
people who have been successful at their
art but not also experiencing life is
meaningful so that's one of the
headlines in the van Gogh blues is that
yes we need the experience of meaning we
need it desperately but we don't need to
only get it from our creative line if
there are other places we can get it
from if we begin to point ourselves in
that direction if we create literally
create write out a menu of meaning
opportunities and see how many different
kinds how many disparate things might
produce the experience of meaning in us
then we have a better way of living our
life where we can say on a given day
well I have no auditions today but that
doesn't mean this day is worthless it
doesn't mean this day is meaningless I
can also do a B and C today and create
some meaning today and I don't have to
write this day off as meaningless just
because I have no auditions today Wow
that's excellent advice yeah you
definitely see that in in Los Angeles
where people have such tunnel vision and
that's great that they live and breathe
whatever it is that they're chasing and
and then when that doesn't happen for
them the Downs are fairly I mean they're
they're really low I don't know if you
see that in the Bay Area too with some
of the tech people I mean it's a
different different pursuit but it's
still there's a creativity to all that
have you seen that also in the tech
world where people put all their eggs in
that basket as well and and then don't
find meaning in other things absolutely
one of the high Christ's see these are
big challenges of our technological
revolution is while the loneliness that
people are experiencing they might be
texting all day and they have five
trillion Facebook friends and four
billion Twitter followers and they're
all lonely so that's one of the the
downsides of being a creative person in
the tech world is that you can't throw
yourself into the next app or the next
technical problem to solve and have no
life in fact my daughter has a book
I'm out coal and she's in the tech world
cold stop being lonely
oh nice that's coming out in in the
spring and that's her focus is on how
one can have a thousand Facebook friends
or what have you and everybody is
experiencing loneliness more
significantly than ever before so that's
absolutely a challenge in the tech world
but I would say all creative people
experience that particular challenge
where they don't actually end up making
enough meaning from their work their
work doesn't provide enough meaning it
it may sometimes provide substantial and
even amazing meaning but it can be very
intermittent you know if you're a
performer let's say you have 33 gigs a
year that's a lot but that means that
there are 330 days when you're not
performing
and unless you're careful those can feel
like meaningless days so whenever your
art is whether it's visual arts or
writing or performing or act whatever it
is these same challenges apply of having
to be smart about how to make additional
meaning in addition to the meaning that
you can make from your creative pursuits
wow that's fascinating um what if
someone is so blind to their own
meaningful you know what what if they
don't know right but but in terms of
like how did they discover what does
have meaning maybe they don't know it
yet maybe it's it's still to be sort of
you know found other than their creative
pursuit how do they uncover that in
themselves they let go of the language
you just used there's a paradigm shift
needed from seeking meaning or finding
meaning to making me ah and you just
used the the language that we've used
for thousands of years it's the it's the
metaphor that most people use the
finding meaning or searching out meaning
metaphor it's time to stop with that
there's no meaning to find there are
decisions to make about life purposes
there are decisions about how we want to
represent ourselves and like what will
make ourselves what will make us proud
of our efforts
so to repeat this simply there's nothing
to find there's meaning to make and so
the activity is stopping that's the
activity it's not searching it's
stopping everything and making decisions
about what to try what meaning
opportunities to seize what meaning
investments to make all without having
any guarantees that you'll actually
experience meaning from your efforts
because you can't know that beforehand
so maybe you'll want to try you know
volunteering at a shelter or writing a
nonfiction book or whatever it might be
that you might want to try in an effort
to make meaning you have to just go
about and try it and see if you actually
experience it as meaningful so that's
what I suggest to folks is that there's
nothing to find nothing to search for
what you have to do is stop and think
through what might work as a meaning
opportunity and then seize it and then
see if it does work so it's like that
carrot kind of dangling don't don't keep
trying to find happiness and all that
create it but but the more you meet
characteristically what happens if you
do that is that you're a Buddhist for
two years then you're you go back to
your Judaism for two years and then you
eat spinach for two years you keep
looking for something so that's going to
provide meaning rather than stopping and
saying there's nothing out there to
search for there were only my decisions
to make about my life purposes well
fascinating many of our film courage
viewers of our videos or listeners of
our podcasts our filmmakers or writers
or actors and one thing we definitely
hear from our audience is they they put
so much into a film they spend a lot of
money either their own or an investor or
their family helps them and then they
get stuck around the point of
distribution with the film and it didn't
either
you know maybe perform as well as they
had wanted or there's issues with the
distributor and some of them stay in
limbo and they get stuck and they feel
distilled this burning desire to make
these movies but they're very frustrated
with the the process or the the process
beyond me
in the film can you give me any advice
to our listeners on when they get to
that sort of point where they've done
their creative work but then putting out
in the world has really put up some
walls for them what you've described is
the rule that's the rule the thing you
just described is what usually happens
what that means is that each filmmaker
has to prove the exception they can't
prove the rule most walks of life all
you have to do is prove the rule if
you're you know working for the federal
government you have to do exactly as
much as the person to the left of you
and the person to the right of you no
more no less that's view that's how you
get along to be a filmmaker you have to
prove the exception so if the filmmaker
to the left of you and the filmmakers to
the right of you is sending out three
emails a day to get distribution you
send out three thousand you have to do
more and that's the headline about
success is doing everything that
everybody else is doing plus also doing
exceptional things though people are not
thinking about ultimately it's about the
gods of whimsy right ultimately there's
is a there's an element of luck involved
oh that's that's unfortunate because
there's nothing anyone can do about that
that's you crossing the street and
running into a famous filmmaker when you
trip and as he's falling he hands you a
contract or something you know there are
all of these stories of accidents and
accidental meetings and what-have-you
but none of that can be orchestrated
sorry all you can do is prove the
exception and that means things like
approaching more people then you may
feel comfortable approaching pestering
people going to more events doing more
things etc it is preposterous that we
first have to work so hard on making a
thing and then work so hard on selling
the thing as preposterous
it's unfair but the universe is not fair
and so that's what we must do we must do
all the work of making the thing and
then all the work of selling it and did
just to repeat myself it would be nice
it would be pretty
you feel or another way but there isn't
Eric how are you the exception in your
own career like you know in terms of the
effort in terms of going above and
beyond with your own you know your
writing and the marketing of your books
well I would say in a lot of different
ways but I'll give one simple example
and I call it internally hit reply and
what I mean by that is if someone gives
me something I want most people stop
there and sit and hit reply and say
thank you I hit reply and ask for more
so if someone wants to publish a book of
mine I hit reply and say wonderful thank
you so much by the way I have another
book and would you be interested in it
now many creative folks and only can
barely hit reply and say thank you and
it would be exceptional if they could
hit reply and say thank you so much can
I also have X Y & Z I'll tell you a
quick little story I still write fiction
and over the years I've written novels
that had not made it into the world and
so recently a publisher wrote to me and
we agreed that he would publish one of
my novels which is lovely and so I click
reply and I said thank you so much by
the way let's do eight novels rather
than one and he wrote back and he said
okay oh that's great you can't have that
experience without asking for it let me
let me leave that there as one of the
ways I take my that's excellent
so knowing that many artists will
experience at least one period of
depression in their lives possibly more
and we're talking about not not
necessarily like biochemical but but
existential depression is there do you
give people sort of a grieving quote
like feeling sorry for yourself period
and then
okay times up got it got us off like I
couldn't like I could take it away from
them well but allow them maybe to wallow
you know in this culture to the Western
culture it's so much about being the
Alpha whatever and and and not showing
any signs of weakness and if someone's
able to just say okay I'm gonna give
myself how you know a little bit of time
to kind of throw a pity party but then
come out of it is that something that
works where we can kind of say all right
I'm gonna be defiant and angry and and
and not want to do this anymore and then
go you know what I think I realize where
maybe my mistake was and I'm gonna come
back up absolutely and what what I ask
the person in that position is how much
time do you want yeah I want to know you
know if you want the weekend you got it
you want three days I'm not so sure
about that
you want four days absolutely not huh so
absolutely and one of we have to feel
feeling you get a reject you're a writer
you get a rejection email you have to
feel the feeling but you want to get
over the feeling of fast as you can not
too fast not unrealistically fast not
crazy fast but fast and so this is
exactly the way I'll talk to a client
absolutely you know have a pity party
for as long as you like just how long is
that how long what would you like and by
Sunday evening what do you want to do to
get started again to get up again that's
all you get Wow so it's almost like an
unwritten contract like okay you have X
amount of days to feel sorry for
yourself but then after that the
grieving period is over and its back to
work kind of thing that's right because
people know they shouldn't go past a
certain point they kind of know what
what's what's legit and what's
completely necessary even if that's the
right word and and when they moved from
actual grieving to something else to now
holding a pessimistic view of the
universe or feeling like life is a chief
or some moving to some other place which
is which they themselves don't want to
remain in interesting do you think some
artists though
they almost enjoy holding that badge of
being wounded because you know we see a
lot of people that have either passed on
or still relevant today and a lot of
teenagers 20 30 years later look up to
those individuals because they have that
angst and we can all identify with
feeling like the world is against us
whether it is or not do you think
something I'd love to hold onto that
badge of unwounded I'm not sure if if
love look to hold on to it it's exactly
the way I would say it if it's a little
hard to shed and it's in a way sometimes
comfortable that is and maybe easier to
hold on to your grievance and your
sadness than to go get yet another set
of headshots and go look for
representation all over again it may be
easier to feel down than to get up and
fight again so I'm not sure they're
loving it but they may find it easier
than getting back up on their feet I
think that we don't understand the
extent to which people do hold on to
their grievances engage in revenge
fantasies are in their heads a lot of
their time a lot of the time in some
down place that they can't quite shake I
wouldn't say they love being there but
there is some something comforting and
familiar about staying there that
sometimes a person can't shed so let's
suppose someone's on maybe more of an
upswing they're more stabilized and
they're ready to create again you say
that inspiration is less important than
just showing up you talk about that and
and some of the ways we put off showing
up sure Tchaikovsky has a quote I like
which is I'm inspired every fifth day
but I only get that fifth day if I show
up the other four right so I believe in
inspiration but I'm not sure we get that
inspiration unless we're actually
showing up and working on the work the
ways people
not say avoid but whatever the right
word is there the way people avoid
getting the work done
they're there many one is to repeat a
tactic that doesn't work namely to stay
in a certain kind of maybe state all day
long maybe I'll practice my instrument
this evening maybe I'll practice the
century my evening that almost always
turns to know that maybe almost always
turns to know by the end of the day not
only are retired over also blue because
we haven't made enough meaning on that
day by virtue of having stayed in that
maybe place all day long so on a
tactical level there's nothing more
important than getting to your creative
or first thing each day with and
obviously some things can't be done
first then I can't go make an audition
happen first thing each day but
whatever's in your power to do whether
it's editing your film and what-have-you
it is very smart if you turn to it first
thing each day and many of the people
listening to this will say I'm not a
morning person
that's not my rhythm that's not natural
for me I understand all that I've heard
every variation of that that can be said
and nevertheless that's still a
wonderful new habit to acquire is to get
to your creative work first thing each
day and there are three reasons for
doing it one is the one is what I've
already said namely you get a lot of
work done if you were to show up seven
days a week to your work first thing
you'd get a ton of work done second you
have the experience of having made some
meaning on that day already and the rest
of the day can be half meaningless and
you won't get so depressed you won't get
so down because you've made some meaning
already and the third is something that
folks don't understand very well and
that is that we think during the night
everybody knows we dream most people
don't know that we also think during the
night and we do lots of creative work
during the night but we don't get to
make use of any of that if as soon as we
turn to the new day all of that vanishes
that great conversation that we had
between Mary and John and our film just
vanishes once we turn to the new day so
if we turn to our work for
thing we get to make use of our sleep
thinking in a very profound way so to
make this long answer short there are
many reasons to institute a morning
creativity practice if you don't do that
already
we interviewed a gentleman in a written
interview named Jeffrey and he did a
documentary about misophonia the the
people that are very sensitive to sound
and one thing I asked him was something
that someone told him that really stood
out and his friend recommended that he
become comfortable with being
uncomfortable and that's quote really
stuck with me I do you think a lot of
artists are afraid of even praise we all
know people are afraid of criticism but
do you think it's uncomfortable for a
lot of artists to receive praise it is
indeed and it can and in major parties
because they don't know how to respond
and I teach all my clients to say thank
you to figure out how to put a period at
the end of that thank you most creative
folks think they have to say more than
that they have to kind of recapitulate
their whole life's journey or something
in that moment all you have to do is say
thank you but to the to the bigger
question there of tolerating discomfort
I think that's really an important point
many people don't get to their creative
work because they're experiencing just a
little anxiety about going into the
unknown not a ton of anxiety but just
enough to prevent them from actually
going and doing their work so they need
some decent things anxiety management
strategies for themselves just something
simple like a breathing exercise or
something that can help them get to
their work and help them break for
resistance but a second kind of
uncomfortableness is is while you're
doing your work what very often happens
I think every creative person recognizes
what I'm about to say and that is you go
into the trance of working sometimes
called flow and you just kind of vanish
you just do your work very nicely
without thinking about anything and then
a truck rumbles by or your cat walks by
or something happens you come out of
that
of concentration that state of flow and
it's often very hard to get back to work
because that initial tendril of anxiety
arises again we feel a little discomfort
little agitation and we run away so it's
very important to have to have an
anxiety management strategy available
for that state that moment where we come
out of flow and are tempted to flee the
encounter tempted to run away if we have
some mechanism some technique some
strategy to stay put
we're going to double our output because
in addition to that first flow state
we're gonna get at least another flow
state if we can just stay put long
enough
what are some common mechanisms that you
can recommend the simplest there's a
little deep breathing that's been known
for thousands of years as a relaxation
technique another one is a cognitive
technique namely to think of thought
that serves you which could be something
as simple as no I'm not running or no
I'm still fine or I'm fine here or some
conscious utterance of the fact that
you're aware that you may want to run
but you're not going to so a breathing
technique is possible a cognitive
technique is possible a relaxation
technique is possible like just rubbing
your shoulder I mean it's odd to say but
just rubbing your shoulder may allow you
to stay put and not run away actors
often learn something called discharge
techniques that is physical ways of
getting rid of the anxiety that's
building up physical weight can be just
taking a little walk around your chair
or silently screaming making a big
screaming face and letting the anxiety
out that way so there are a lot of
techniques I think I have maybe 20
techniques in my book master and
creative anxiety and then I have another
book called performance anxiety so so
there are a ton of techniques available
typically a creative person does not
manage to own any of these techniques
they hear about them they hear about
this anxiety management they take or
that one but they don't actually
practice one and own it
and have it available to them when
they're actually feeling anxious just
parenthetically a lot of the folks I
work with may have a meditation practice
or a yoga practice or something else
that keeps them calm during the yoga or
during the meditation but it doesn't
necessarily keep them calm when they're
going to an audition so what you want
are tactics that actually work when your
anxiety is at your highest not when
you're already calm most most creative
folks don't have an anxiety management
technique that actually works for them
where we talked about when someone does
praise you just thank you and then
period and being comfortable with that
on the flip side you know we're in this
new age where people can put comments
and tweet you and all of that and I know
back in I think it was 2009 I watched an
interview with writer John Updike and
the person called in and just flat out
said I don't like your books at all and
I think your stories and he handled it
so beautifully he deflected he laughed
I reckon one graciously deflect
criticism because I know I I'm sure
maybe he didn't really feel that way or
maybe he did but he did it in such a way
that was so graceful that the other
person really kind of showed who they
were and he remained it was quite a
comment but happened because as I
mentioned my daughter has a book coming
out and she's writing she's blogging for
Psychology Today and AH some of her
blogs have had as many as 300,000 views
or 500 thousand views so she sent me an
email last year sometime when she
started blogging shitin she said with an
exclamation point
I have haters right and it's almost
actually a compliment because you know
then you're actually creating a ripple
in the world you hold it that way and
whether you take it as a compliment you
have to grow a thick skin I did a whole
book on this called toxic criticism
about how to not all criticism gets
under our skin it's funny how life
operates sometimes somebody can say
something very harsh to us and it
doesn't register and then the next
person can say something very
mild and it does register so you never
can know which thing is going to get
under your skin but you need tactics for
dealing with those things which get
under your skin I'm guessing it very
little could get under update' skin
anymore
very little can get under my skin I
write in controversial areas I write
about you know atheism and critical
psychiatry and all kinds of things that
get me haters sure and I know what
people are gonna say and I don't really
care huh but that's a long journey to
not caring and every once in a while
something will still get under my skin
and then I have to temporize I have to
walk around the lake so to speak and
just let it let it dissipate you don't
want there you don't want to hit reply
you never want to enter into
conversation with a hater never in a
million years it wastes your time and it
gets you embroiled in something that's a
absolutely no use to you so I guess my
headline for this would be to be mature
in your understanding that you know if
you if it's in your own body where you
want drama mystery onyx and stuff this
is gonna be a great opportunity for you
to get some drama in your life is to
start fighting with your haters but it's
not going to serve you those are not
dramas that are going to serve you or
try the Abe Lincoln approach just write
a letter but don't send it and I
actually described I call it the dear
critic letter I described that in the
toxic criticism book I think that's a
smart on tactic to write that letter and
not send it the reason I think that that
tactic is so wise is that there's
something in the enterprise of writing
that letter were in the beginning you're
just it's just one expletive deleted
after another
you're just railing at the critic but as
you work on that letter often you'll
come to some realization about some
truth in what the critic is said that is
you may end up with a little bit of
actual learning a little bit of
self-awareness because not everything a
critic says is wrong or mean-spirited
sometimes critics have things to say
that would be good if we could hear so
my basic orientation is a ignore the
criticism but be while you're ignoring
it just out of a corner of one eye
if there's something there that maybe
you need to know about and you've talked
about the the the busy mind the monkey
mind and that it prevents a lot of
artists from actually creating because
they don't they're so busy thinking
about what's on Twitter and and oh
should I check my facebook status or
what where do I have to go to pick up
this or that
that they don't actually quiet it to get
to creating can you talk about how to
quiet it and and how we're even more
distracted today than probably ever
before yeah
cognitive therapist have a simple
three-step procedure for doing that kind
of quieting or reducing the first is
actually care what you say to yourself a
lot of the things that we say we only
have here or don't hear at all because
we're defensive creatures and often we
don't even hear what we're saying what
we're thinking so that the first step is
to actually hear our own thoughts the
second is to dispute those utterances
that don't serve us and I want to come
back to that in a second and the third
is to substitute more affirmative
language or a more positive language so
that's pretty simple to say and actually
pretty simple to do to to hear and
dispute and substitute what's harder is
to get the following idea clearly in
mind and that is to only think thoughts
that serve you and by that I mean the
truth or falsity of a thought isn't
relevant we get held hostage by true
thoughts because we think wow since it's
a true thought I have the cabinet so I
have to believe it since it's true let
me give you an example you walk into a
bookstore and you say wow there are a
lot of writers in the world that's a
true thought that doesn't serve a writer
to think it's true but not useful many
of the thoughts a creative person is
thinking are true but not useful
they're thinking about the competition
difficulties what have you
if you can train yourself to say wow
that's a true thought but it doesn't
serve me to think it and you can really
reduce your overtime you can reduce your
distress a lot and even start to
extinguish those thoughts so that when
you walk into a bookstore you don't say
to yourself wow there are a lot of
writers you say to yourself hmm I wonder
what hasn't been covered in this
bookstore that I can write about that is
you start to think differently about
life and about your life as a creative
person by virtue of the fact that you're
no longer thinking thoughts that don't
serve you excellent
Eric how much do family of origin issues
play out in to how an artist views his
or her work let's say that they're
familiar role is is one of the golden
child where they can do nothing wrong
and everything's you hear angels in the
background or the opposite whether the
family scapegoat and nothing's ever good
enough how much does that family label
place on their output and how they view
their creativity a ton and it's not
really just the label it's the way those
trauma sounds like a large word to use
for these things but I think it's a fair
word the way those early traumatic
experiences still exist in our being
somewhere so if there are all kinds of
there's different kinds of examples one
kind of example is the family where
somebody where one of the parents or
even somebody more distant than a parent
and uncle was a famous artist that the
child isn't that family often has a
terrifically difficult time getting on
with their creative work they often go
into the creative arts and then there's
this something tremendously difficult
about having had somebody famous in the
family and I think anybody who knows the
Hollywood world would know how that
works and why so often the children of
celebrities end up with their addiction
problems and their depression problems
and their suicide problems and
what-have-you
so there's something very burdensome
about
Jamin the family's success in the family
just as burdensome or or differently
burdensome is being chastised and
denigrated and minimized your whole
childhood and that happens to an awful
lot of children sometimes it's
mean-spirited on the parents part
sometimes it's more inadvertent but
whether it's inadvertent or
mean-spirited it's very hard for that
child to get over that over time
a typical manifestation of that will be
having a million ideas for things but
not being able to complete any of those
ideas always having incomplete work
scattered around the apartment so to
speak so we're on a gigantic subject but
the headline is family of origin issues
really do matter well as we wrap up I
understand you have a new book coming
out it's called the future of mental
health can you tell us about that yes it
is out now actually and it's out in many
different ways including in an audio
book so if any of your listeners like
audiobooks and the subtitle is
deconstructing the mental disorder
paradigm and by that I mean most folks
don't understand to what extent the
whole idea of mental disorders is a
flawed idea that it's actually just a
certain kind of label and a certain kind
of interaction that happens between a
suffering person and a so to speak
mental health professional so in this
book I try to do the work of
deconstructing that paradigm of
explaining to the reader and this will
sound funny and they're gonna have to
read the book to really understand it
explain for reader how there's no such
thing as depression or schizophrenia or
the other labels that exist there are
experiences like despair and hearing
voices there are lots of experiences but
the labels that get associated with
those experiences are just labels that
folks sitting around the table decide to
impose around a set of experiences and
what flows from that imposing our so
called psychiatric medication which are
not really drugs
but nearly chemicals with strong effects
so you can tell that I'm saying the big
thing and a mouthful what I would
recommend to folks is that they just go
visit Amazon and read some of the
reviews of the book the future of mental
health and see if the book seems
interesting to them
that's fascinating is that because uh is
it the DSM I don't know five or whatever
has now talked about a spectrum rather
than these labels of well this person's
this and that but there's more like this
continuum whether don't they fall in or
what what you're saying is interesting
because that's how many people today
look at the DSM as maybe flawed in
certain respects but probably basically
okay but the headline is it's completely
not okay the DSM is essentially a
fraudulent document and there are many
many proofs of that and many
explanations of that as to why it came
into being in the 1950s and how it's
been supported over the years as the way
to go so to speak but it's it's really
not a legitimate document at all well as
we as we end our podcast today anything
you'd like to tell to our listeners
anything you'd like to say thank you for
your time this has been wonderful no
nothing in particular obviously I've
done many different books so depending
on you know a person's particular issues
if addictions the issue I have a book
called creative recovery that's probably
the right book if it's anxiety I have a
couple of those books if it's depression
I recommend the van Gogh blues or a book
called rethinking depression so I guess
my my last word would be just to come
visit me at Eric nasal comm and see what
I do excellent well thank you so much
for your time I've enjoyed watching your
videos online with other interviewers I
want to check out more of your books and
I appreciate the work that you do thank
you Eric yeah thank you very beautiful
conversation thank you hey Cara okay
take care thank you